hi herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF heute live
schön dass ihr dabei seid bisher hat die
nordkoreanische russische Freundschaft
vor allem auf der gemeinsamen Front
gegen die USA basiert ja und dann hat
Russland die Ukraine angegriffen und
jetzt anscheinend munitionsprobleme wir
sprechen heute über das geplante Treffen
zwischen Kim Jong Un und Vladimir Putin
in Wladiwostok lasst uns mal zu Anfang
auf die aktuellen Bilder schauen
da sehen wir es vor wenigen Stunden gab
es die Ankunft per gepanzertem Zug im
Bahnhof von Wladiwostok in Russland
Nordkoreas Diktator Kim wird empfangen
von Moskau Umweltminister kostenlos da
sehen wir gerade noch aus dem Zug
steigen
und tatsächlich war auch genau in diesem
Zug das letzte Mal
Kims letzte Auslandsreise 2019 und da
war das tatsächlich derselbe Zug
derselbe Ort und derselbe
Gesprächspartner hier sehen wir den
Empfang von Moskau aus Umweltminister
Koslow und wann genau das Treffen mit
Putin stattfindet das ist aktuell unklar
und wir fragen uns heute Russland und
Nordkorea ist das die neue neue Allianz
im Krieg gegen die Ukraine denn von
diesem Treffen wird erwartet dass es
eventuell um einen Deal gehen könnte bei
dem unter anderem Nordkorea Waffen an
Russland liefern könnte wir schauen
heute gemeinsam darauf was von
sämtlichen Seiten von diesem Treffen
erwartet wird also von Nordkorea und von
Russland und das bespreche ich wie immer
nicht alleine sondern mit Gästen zum
einen mit Militär Experte Christian
Mölling von der Deutschen Gesellschaft
für auswärtige Politik und mit der
korea-expertin Teresa vom Kurier
europcenter fellow an der FU Berlin und
natürlich wie immer auch mit euch wenn
ihr Fragen zu diesem Thema habt oder
einfach mal eure Meinung mit uns teilt
dann schreibt uns immer gerne einfach im
youtube-chat oder per Mail an die jetzt
eingeblendete Adresse und jetzt schreibt
mir aber erstmal zu Militär Experte
Christian Mölling hallo
hallo guten Abend
dich ist denn dieses Treffen was jetzt
intervie international drauf geguckt
wird für Russland wie wichtig wäre
dieser vermutete Waffen Deal für
Russland
ja das hängt ja erstmal davon ab was da
überhaupt geliefert werden würde das
muss man glaube ich erst damit an einem
stellen dass sie noch überhaupt nichts
unterschrieben ist gleichzeitig wissen
wir das Nordkorea bereits schon einmal
Munition zumindest wahrscheinlich auch
Waffen geliefert hat für Russland ist es
insofern wichtig als dass es
offensichtlich große Probleme hat seinen
Nachschub sicherzustellen für Nordkorea
ist es wichtig weil man natürlich damit
quasi ein wenig mehr auf Augenhöhe mit
Russland kommt wobei natürlich der
Empfang erst mal durch den
Umweltminister vielleicht noch keine
gleiche Wertschätzung ist wieder
anfangen durch hoffentlich dann Wladimir
Putin das ist ja sicherlich zumindest
das auch das spekuliert
ja und was so ein bisschen im Zentrum
der Spekulationen um dieses Treffen
steht ist ja die eventuelle
Waffenlieferungen von Nordkorea an
Russland und über was für einen
Waffenarsenal Nordkorea überhaupt
verfügt das hat sich mein Kollege Thomas
Gonser für uns angeschaut
vor drei Tagen Nordkoreas Diktator Kim
lässt zum 75 jahrestag der
Staatsgründung groß auffahren
Soldatinnen und Soldaten Waffen
Kriegsgerät als knallbunte Show als
Demonstration von Stärke gegenüber der
vermeintlichen Bedrohung durch Südkorea
und Japan was aber hat Kim wirklich in
seinen waffenarsenalen wiederum drei
Tage vorher Stapellauf für eine
Atomwaffe für Nordkoreas erstes nuklear
U-Boot weitere würden folgen das sagt
jedenfalls Kim und behauptet das Boot
könne bist du zehn Atomraketen tragen
und abfeuern allerdings Experten
bezweifeln die Funktionsfähigkeit
zweifelsohne aber habe das Land eine der
größten flotten der Welt geschätzt 64
bis 86 U-Boote
für Russland im Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine besonders interessant
Kurzstrecken Raketen beispielsweise vom
Typ kN 23 sie sind dem russischen
iscanda Raketensystem ähnlich Moskau
könnte sie ohne große Umstellung
einsetzen
denkbar auch Lieferung von Munition
Geschosse für Russlands Artillerie und
für Panzer aus Sowjet Zeiten auch die
setzt Moskau in der Ukraine ein
überhaupt Pjöngjang verfügt primär über
sowjetische Waffensysteme baut zugleich
in eigenen Fabriken auch neues Equipment
was genau und wie viel gesicherte Infos
aus dem abgeschotteten Land gibt es
nicht Beobachter sind sich aber sicher
es gibt viele Waffen sowie
Munitionslager und die sind riesig
ja wir haben sie eben gehört sehr
konkrete Aussagen darüber zu treffen was
Nordkorea an Waffen besitzt das ist
schwer aber es gibt zum Beispiel die
Kurzstreckenrakete vom Typ K n23 Herr
Mölling was würde denn so eine Lieferung
ganz konkret für Russland aktuell
bringen an der Front gegen Ukraine
davon ab wie viel geliefert wird wissen
dass Russland immer größere Probleme hat
im Bereich der Marschflugkörper oder
andere Flugkörper tatsächlich noch etwas
aufwarten zu können als der teilweise
auch Raketen bereits eingesetzt die
eigentlich primär für die Abwehr von
anderen Flughafen gedacht worden sind
von daher mag das für einen Moment
helfen ähm wir wissen aber auch dass
Russland in der Vergangenheit diese
Waffen fallen als Terrorverfahren
eingesetzt hat also im Krieg hilft es an
der auf der in der Front nicht
möglicherweise um weiterhin den Terror
gegen die Ukraine aufrecht zu erhalten
aber dann muss natürlich dort Korea sich
auch irgendwann fragen wann es selber
seine eigene angriffsfähigkeit
Abwehrfähigkeit so stark schwächtig
gerade wenn es diese Waffen Weg gibt von
denen ist wahrscheinlich nicht so
wahnsinnig viele hat und die für die
Verteidigung Nordkoreas aus der sich
Nordkoreas zumindest
ganz wichtig sind
wir haben hier direkt mal eine
der Community viele fragen sich wie soll
denn die oder wie sollte im Fall eines
Deals die Logistik laufen und hier gibt
es auch ein User der gleich mal bedenken
oder Zweifel hat ich gesagt jemand auf
Youtube die Tonnen die aus Nordkorea
täglich zu Frauen in die Ukraine
geschafft werden müssen schaffen doch
Nordkoreas und Russlands Logistik nicht
oder
das finde ich ist eine gute Frage es
geht in der Tat nicht nur darum das
Material zu haben sondern auch noch an
die Front zu bekommen und die Ukraine
bemüht sich ja nach Leipzig treffen und
sehr erfolgreich die Logistik die ihnen
ja Reichweite ihrer Raketen liegt so
weit runter zu fahren dass es für
Russland immer schwieriger wird dazu
kommt auch das Problem haben wir
überhaupt hat Russland überhaupt
Menschen die in der Lage sind mit dem
Material umzugehen auch wenn man jetzt
sagt Russland könnte das einfach so
bedienen dahinter würde ich ihn
Fragezeichen machen denn das können sie
ja nicht mit einem einfachen guten
machen werden mal 6 Monate durch eine
russische Zwangslager durchgelaufen ist
ich glaube darauf liegt auch nicht der
das große augenmerksam sondern es gibt
glaube ich eher um die Munition für die
einzellerie auch das ist knapper
geworden und offensichtlich ist Russland
noch nicht in der Lage gewesen die
eigene Produktion so stark wieder
hochzufahren dass man hier tatsächlich
wieder
gut unterwegs ist gleichzeitig kommt
noch ein anderes Problem mit dazu
Ukraine ist relativ erfolgreich in den
letzten Wochen und Monaten gewesen die
russische Artillerie zu zerstören auch
das muss ersetzt werden mit Russland
weiter irgendwo Schritt halten möchte
und es wird dann sehr lange dauern bis
das nordkoreanische Material da ist und
es ist auch nicht so erfolgreich oder
effektiv wie man das vielleicht in der
Vergangenheit von etwas moderneren
russischen System erwartet hat oder
gesehen hat vor allem wahrscheinlich
nicht was die Reichweite
ich schaue hier gerade so den Chat und
die User und Userin interessiert auch
die andere Seite eines potenziellen die
jetzt hier schreibt Roland Gerhard auf
Youtube interessanter für mich ist was
Russland im Gegenzug liefern würde ich
befürchte Atom U-Boote oder die
Technologie dafür wie sie das der
Experte
also ich glaube nicht dass so eine
atomobute liefern würde ich glaube schon
dass
Nordkorea darauf schielt möglicherweise
Raketen und ein bisschen
Satellitentechnologie oder
Weltraumtechnologie zu bekommen das eine
oder andere womit man zu Hause
quasi weitermachen kann das ist
sicherlich ganz interessant denn die
innovationsfähigkeiten und Co ist
natürlich enorm gehängt durch die das
durch dass die katholische Regime das
könnte eine Option sein aber
gleichzeitig sollte man bauen die
unterschätzen das ist die politische
Symbolik so groß ist dass quasi Russland
politische Währung investiert um
aufzuwerten
und er einen einen Deal bekommt auch
politischer Ebene die den er eigentlich
schon lange haben wollte den Russland
aber lange Zeit abgelehnt hat für
Russland war die Beziehung zu China viel
viel wichtiger jetzt ist man in einer
Situation in der Mann quasi von der Hand
in den Mund leben muss wo man gerne
Partner mit Staaten wird die nicht nur
auf dunklen Seite stehen sondern von
denen man früher gedacht hat dass sie
eigentlich zwei drei Stufen auf der
Leiter unter einem stehen das ist quasi
das Investment dass man sich herunter
begibt zu diesen Staaten
ja und passend dazu zu dieser
politischen Dimensionen dieses Treffens
haben wir noch eine Frage auf Youtube
geht eine ähnliche Richtung was ist
davon zu halten wenn Putin sich jetzt
schon an Kim wenden muss wer wird der
nächste Partner sein der Waffen liefert
finde ich auch eine gute Frage die wir
können nur hoffen dass die die Anzahl
der der dunklen Freunde nicht mehr wird
oder das jene Staaten die möglicherweise
wankelmütig werden nicht auf die Idee
kommt zu liefern aber ich glaube das das
größte Problem wäre wenn tatsächlich
China in Lieferung einsteigen würde wir
wissen oder wir haben Andeutungen in die
Richtung dass China zwar keine
kompletten Waffen liefert aber noch in
erheblichen Maße Komponenten liefert
wenn ich China Nordkorea quasi als
durchschleusungsmöglichkeit nutzen würde
für eigene Munition oder Waffen dann
wäre das sicherlich etwas was auch die
Konflikte zwischen Washington und
picking nicht unberührt lassen würde die
Frage ist ob Peking tatsächlich dieses
Risiko eingehen würde klar ist dass
jetziger Abwägung das Peking kein
Interesse hat das Muskel den Krieg
verliert man will aber auch nicht zu
sehr in dieser Situation involviert
werden und man fürchtet dahin im Grunde
genommen schon auch dass die amerik
möglicherweise ihre Technologie
Sanktionen gegen China stärker
hochfahren können
inwiefern kann man denn dieses Treffen
sowohl Nordkorea als auch Russland so
eine Art Juniorpartner von China auch
als Reaktion darauf werten dass China
vielleicht nicht so umfassend Dinge
geliefert hat wie Russland das erwartet
hat
sich sehr bedeckt gehalten was die
Möglichkeiten von Lieferungen angeht
oder hat sich sehr zurückhaltend gezeigt
zufällig das glaube ich bekommen das ist
glaube ich Korrektur von daher glaube
ich dass China weiterhin versuchen wird
dann nicht in der Scheidung zu treten
wir können hier das ist sagen wir
spekulieren hier sehr viel rum was
passieren könnte klar ist da jetzigen
dafür halten das Russland die Ressourcen
die ist Bräuche um den Krieg auch nur
einigermaßen weiterzuführen
offensichtlich kurzfristig zumindest bis
diese Lieferung da sind mittelfristig
gar nicht hat und deswegen sucht man
händeringend danach und was sie
längerfristigen politischen Konsequenzen
sind das scheint Moskau doch
einigermaßen egal sein zu müssen weil
die alternativen einfach davon Rasen
danke erstmal bis hierhin wir sprechen
uns gleich noch mal und gucken noch ein
bisschen expliziter auf die aktuelle
Lage an der Front und die mögliche
Auswirkungen eines möglichen Deals bis
gleich
gerne bis gleich
ja wir hören das schon raus nordkorea
ist einfach ein Land über das wir
unglaublich wenig Wissen das mit harten
Sanktionen belegt ist und das in der
internationalen Gemeinschaft dadurch
auch ziemlich isoliert da steht von
einem potenziellen Waffendeal verspricht
sich also haben wir gerade gehört vor
allem Russland Unterstützung durch
militärisches Gerät aber was hätte
eigentlich Nordkorea davon was sind Kim
Jong uns Erwartungen an dieses
Interessen und darüber spreche ich jetzt
mit Korea Expertin Teresa Novotna guten
Abend Frau
hallo guten Abend
was ist denn ihre Einschätzung ihre
Einschätzung der anderen Seite mit
welchem Interesse geht gemacht habe Kim
Jong-un in dieses Treffen mit Putin
ja also ich war eigentlich ursprünglich
nicht es gibt dich das überhaupt zu
einem Gefühl Treffen mit Putin kommt
weil ein was in dir könnte man schon
längst abschließen unterzeichnen also
dafür braucht man eigentlich keinen
Gipfel Treffen zwischen Präsidentin und
daher ich finde man sollte das Treffen
und die Situation jetzt ein bisschen
also in einem größeren Bild anschauen
also
es geht nicht nur um und um die Waffen
aber es geht auch
die diplomatische Beziehungen
und dabei würde ich gerne betonen es
also bei uns also wer gerne sehen
alle die drei Länder in dem
Gebiet also Russland Nordkorea und China
also ein
verbindest aber natürlich gibt es auch
Unterschiede und ich finde schon
versucht mit seiner russlandspolitik
sozusagen
auch ein bisschen seine Abhängigkeit von
China
zumindest also
eigentlich wir können daran denken die
ganze Welt sagt ja wir wollen keine
dicken von China sondern wir möchten
jetzt gehen und ähm
eigentlich
versuchte dasselbe zu tun
also auch mit engeren Beziehungen mit
Russland seine Abhängigkeit oder die
oder die Abhängigkeit von Nordkorea
von China ein bisschen zu mir und dann
gleichzeitig natürlich
nicht zu verlieren
nicht nur dass er schon gegen den
Sanktionen liegt
aber das Land hat sich auch viel mehr
von dem äußeren Welt
eigentlich die
Selbstisolation während der coronazeit
war für höher als durch die Sanktionen
daher eine Bedrohung dass vielleicht
weitere Sanktionen kommen
das macht die nichts sondern es ist
irgendwie so
wichtig für ihn da habe ich gerade mal
eine spezielle Nachfrage zu den
Sanktionen das wissen wir ja schon lange
aus Nordkorea die sind sehr belegt mit
internationalen Sanktionen die auch
immer wieder zu innenpolitischen
Problemen in Nordkorea führen was sind
denn da vielleicht so zwei drei Gründe
also in politische aktuelle Probleme die
kim Jong und zu diesem Treffen bewegen
ja also natürlich für ihn das Treffen
ist wirklich ein eine tolle Gelegenheit
sozusagen so wenn du opportunity auf
Englisch
weil er hat die Möglichkeit wieder der
Welt zu zeigen dass das er mit großen
Mann haben verhandeln kann es ist auch
interessante Zeit heutzutage weil gerade
die
sich die nordkore ein bisschen öffnet
noch vor zwei drei Wochen waren die
Grenzen mehr oder weniger dazu aber
jetzt in der letzten Jahr zwei drei
Wochen sehen wir
dass Personen die notkrone die in
Ausland schon
längst leben also die die nicht werden
der Corona nach Hause kommen konnte dass
ich gerade jetzt zurückkommen
also innenpolitisch das ist eine ganz
andere Situation und
der Fakt dass
er gemacht habe wieder nach Ausland
reist ist auch ein Signal also für die
heimliche Population aber auch außen
dass
seine so die Isolation die selbst
Isolation
er verändern möchte und jetzt wird ja
auch gerade darüber gesprochen ob ähm äh
ob Russland vielleicht auch als
gewissermaßen ein Lieferant von
Nahrungsmitteln oder zum Anfang
Nahrungsmitteln aber auch von
innovativen Techniken wie
Satellitentechnik dienen könnte oder
ja ja das kann natürlich
besprochen werden
also es geht nicht nur um
massenlieferungen sondern Russland kann
auch mit Nahrungsmitteln nordkorean
beliefern aber wir wissen nicht wie
schlimm die Situation im Lande ist weil
die ganze internationale Kommunikation
also insbesondere die internationale
Hilfsorganisationen aber auch die
diplomatische Missionen die müssen
zwei Jahren das Land verlassen
wir wissen nicht genau wie wie die
Situation im Lande aussieht aber
natürlich
kann auch darauf hoffen dass er aus
Russland nicht nur also die die
Waffentechnologien
erwähnt hat sondern auch Nahrungsmittel
bekommen könnte
aber ich würde gerne betonen also man
sollte das Treffen er politisch also
also
größeres Bild da sind viel mehr als ja
was für ein Austausch kann zwischen
Nordkorea und Russland stattfinden
dieses Treffen also als ein
gewissermaßen politisches Zeichen nach
außen durch Nordkorea Frau nur wortna
vielen vielen Dank dass Sie meine Fragen
beantwortet haben und schönen Abend noch
danke schön
und wir gehen jetzt noch einmal zu
Militärexperte Christian
Mölling und gucken uns mal an was diese
eventuellen Waffenlieferung
Nordkoreas an Russland generell für die
Lage in der Ukraine bedeuten für den
Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine
hallo
wir haben eine ganze Menge Fragen an Sie
wenn ich hier mal in den Chat gucke und
das haben wir noch gar nicht
angesprochen und das ist natürlich auch
wichtig für die Situation wenn sie
Armbrust fragt auf Youtube weiß man
eigentlich wie gut die Waffen der
Nordkoreaner sind die sie liefern war in
den Einspielern die wir gesehen haben
sich das ja mal recht anschaulich aus
was da bei den Paraden präsentiert wird
die Paraden und die Bilder die wir
bekommen die sind ja auch extra für uns
gemacht also extra shiny hat ein Tier
real wahrscheinlich auch mit westlicher
Software doch mal nachbereitet damit das
besonders schön aussieht und wie auch
Anfang darüber zu sprechen denn die
Diskussion die wir führen die führt man
ja in Nordkorea nicht die kann man da
nicht führen oder wenn man es tut dann
ist man seinen kopflos ich glaube das
muss man sich hier ganz klar vor Augen
führen das ist Material für uns das hier
gemacht worden ist die verlässlich das
ist darüber gibt es nur ich sag mal
Spekulationen das ist das Problem
das sozusagen die Nachrichten Aufklärung
mit der nordkoreanischen Diktatur hat
dass da relativ wenig rauskommt
wir gehen davon aus dass viel von dem
Material einfach altes so wird Material
ist das Magie und danach funktionieren
das ist aber trotzdem mit wahrscheinlich
mit hohen Risiken in der Benutzung
belastet ob es überhaupt noch
funktioniert wie gut die treffsicher
dieses Systeme sind alles das muss man
mit Fragezeichen versehen also ich alles
in allem erstmal relativ
entspannt was die die militärischen
Effekte dieser eines möglichen Deals
angeht von dem wir erstmal nicht wissen
ob er stattfindet das haben wir eben
auch gehört wann er kommt und wandern
überhaupt dieses Material an der Front
ankommen soll wir haben auf der anderen
Seite die die Zeitperspektive bei den
Kämpfen jetzt direkt die wahrscheinlich
noch anderthalb Monate Zeit haben Raum
greifen zu wirken und dann geht man im
Grunde genommen in eine Winterphase
hinein ich denke mal dafür wird wenn es
eine Lieferung überhaupt gibt diese
Lieferung zu spät kommen hier noch
irgendeiner Art und Weise das Blatt zu
wenden selbst wenn sie käme würde sie
nur das abdämpfen der russischen
Verluste bedeuten
und vielleicht noch ein Puzzlestück mehr
zum Kontext dieses Treffens zwischen Kim
und Putin das findet nämlich am Rande
eines anderen Treffens statt zu dem
Putin in Wladiwostok geladen hat nämlich
das zum Essen
Economic Forum das ist quasi eine Art
Wirtschaftstreffen was auch gerade in
bloody Rostock stattfindet was ist denn
die Bedeutung dieses Treffens worum geht
es da und was ist die Bedeutung für
dieses Treffen
also Moskau hat ja schon lange versucht
alternative Poren für sich aufzubauen wo
es selber sozusagen als Hegemonialmacht
wirken kann das dürfte eines dieser
Treffen sein dabei wird nicht bedeutsam
um große
wirtschaftsströme gehen sicherlich eher
auch eine Möglichkeit erneut einen
Auftritt für Putin zu generieren dessen
Bildmaterial zu uns kommt und mit dem
Putin Nachrichten und senden kann also
auch das hat er jetzt schon gemacht er
ist selber nicht verhandlungsbereit
Kabine kann nur dann sozusagen an
Verhandlungstisch kommen wenn ihnen die
Puste ausgeht also er bestätigt im
Grunde alles das was viele Leute hier im
Westen auf der Expertenseite immer
wieder gesagt haben Russland selber ist
nicht verhandlungsbereit und solange die
Ukraine in der Lage ist sich zu wehren
musste sich auch einem diktatfrieden aus
Moskau nicht beugen also von daher ist
die Idee man bloß gut zu reden vom
russischen Präsidenten selber eigentlich
widerlegt
wenn wir jetzt mal ähm auf die Front in
der Ukraine gucken wo immer noch die
ukrainische Gegenoffensive läuft aber
nicht mehr so wahnsinnig viel passiert
aktuell können Sie uns da mal die Lage
zusammenfassen und vielleicht auch den
zeitlichen Rahmen in dem eine
potenzielle Munition dort überhaupt
ankommen würde
ja also erstmal muss man sagen ich
glaube an der an der Front oder an den
vielen Frontabschnitten passiert
tatsächlich sehr viel wir haben es uns
angewöhnt Fortschritte in Kilometer zu
messen das ist das absolut falsche es
geht ja nicht zur Zeit darum Kilometer
zu machen auch wenn das Endziel ist das
gesamte besetzte Gebiet wieder zurück zu
nehmen dafür sind neuralgische Punkte
Schlüsselposition notwendig die man
erobern muss und wir haben in der
Vergangenheit immer wieder darüber
gesprochen wie unmögliches eigentlich
ist das hinzubekommen gerade wenn man
keine Luftunterstützung hat westliche
Militärs würde eine solche Operation gar
nicht erst Unternehmen die würden die
Minenfelder als nicht durchfahrbar
ansehen die Ukraine macht es trotzdem
das bedeutet da passiert ganz viel auch
an Kämpfen findet sehr viel statt das
was nicht stattfindet ist eben das jetzt
auf einmal schlagartig nach Hollywood
Mania ihren Durchbruch passiert und man
in die Abendsonne reitet und die können
zurückerobert ist das ist glaube ich
auch wieder eine falsche
dieses Bild dass ich irgendwie
unheimlich festgesetzt hat bei uns es
geht unter hohen Verlusten für die
Ukraine schrittweise voran und wir sehen
dass es im Süden die Möglichkeit gibt
hier und da weiter in die zweite
Verteidigungslinie einzusickern die
Ukraine ist in der Lage gewesen noch
mehr kleine Brückenköpfe auf der
Ostseite des japper zu Ende zu
etablieren auch das ist kein Durchbruch
es bedeutet aber das russlandskräfte
gebunden werden und das müssen uns immer
wieder vor Augen führen hier geht's um
relative Kräfte Verhältnisse Russland
ist nicht mehr in der Lage alle die
Angriffe oder auch nur
Verteidigungslinie die es aufgebaut hat
anständig mit Soldaten zu versorgen und
die Ukraine erhört erhöht die Dilemmata
die Anzahl die lämmerter und die drei
Dramatik in diesem Zusammenhang und
Russland muss jetzt schon Einheiten
abziehen offensichtlich oder einsetzen
die eigentlich für offensiv Operationen
eingesetzt werden sollen also die Mieter
operate
die eigentlich eine strategische Reserve
darstellen das zeigt wenn diese Berichte
stimmen das Russland immer mehr und mehr
auch bei den bei den Hochqualifizierten
Soldaten wirklich an eine an eine Grenze
Gerät die ist immer weiter schwer machen
Russland wird sich sicherlich versuchen
in den Winter zu retten und deswegen
kommt es darauf an dass Europa und damit
auch Deutschland ein ordentliches
Winterpaket Schnüren denn die Art des
Krieges wird sich natürlich im Winter
wieder ändern
ja wenn wir jetzt mal in diesem Szenario
bleiben Nordkorea würde
Munition an Russland liefern was wäre
dann quasi das Pendant der Gegenseite
also was braucht die Ukraine aktuell in
diesem Zustand der Front am dringendsten
die Ukraine braucht das was sie glaube
ich immer wieder gesagt hat und was wir
aber nicht hören wollten sie braucht
weiterhin ganz viel von allem die
Kampfpanzer die Schützenpanzer Gott sei
Dank für Deutschland ist so eine
schützen aber auch gerade die lang
reichweitige Munition also das sind
sozusagen die Raketen die helfen die
Logistik zu trennen um damit einfach
Russlands Soldaten an der Front
auszutrocknen wenn die keine Munition
mehr haben können sie eben nichts
anderes mehr tun als sich zurückziehen
das ist das Ziel der ganzen Geschichte
und die Frage ist ob wir bereit sind das
was wir gesagt haben was wir tun wollen
nämlich Verantwortung übernehmen und
möglich machen das Russland die Ukraine
zurückgibt dass wir dem auch Taten
folgen lassen zurzeit ist ja viel offen
und man muss sagen der Winter steht
zumindest planerisch gesehen vor der Tür
alles das was in drei Monaten da sein
muss um die Ukraine auch für den
winterfest zu machen das muss jetzt ähm
geplant und beliefert werden
was ändert sich denn
die Wetterkonditionen auf die
Konditionen in denen in dieser
Angriffskrieg stattfindet im Winter also
was sind da die besonderen
Herausforderungen
wir gehen durch eine Zeit der
sogenannten weglosigkeit das heißt so
rund um den november herum das große
Regenfälle geben in der ganzen Region so
dass sogenannte raumgreifendoperationen
nicht mehr möglich sind mit den Panzern
einfach im Schlamm stecken weil die so
schwer sind der Boden total aufgeweicht
ist der friert dann irgendwann wieder zu
dann werden wieder andere Operation
möglich
aber in dieser Zeit ist es alles sehr
schwer damit sich nicht wahnsinnig viel
bewegen und für die Ukraine ist die
Herausforderung auf der einen Seite
Russland keine Atempause zu gönnen
ständig sozusagen Russland in Bewegung
zu halten wenn es geht sozusagen zurück
zu drängen und auf der anderen Seite
wird Russland wahrscheinlich in dieser
Zeit seine Angriffe mit Drohnen erhöhen
das heißt sie sind Terror erhöhen und
das kennen wir aus dem letzten Winter
schon dass man wieder versuchen wird die
zivile Infrastruktur noch Verstärker
anzugreifen weil man kann ja militärisch
nichts ausrichten und dagegen hilft nur
auf der einen Seite eben tatsächlich
mehr Luft ab soweit das noch irgendwo
möglich ist die Produktion wird schon
hochgefahren aber auch da gibt es mehr
die Amerikaner kaufen zusätzliche Panzer
zu für die für die Luftabwehr und
gleichzeitig eben wie gesagt die
Logistik
soweit es geht nicht nur kaputt gemacht
zu haben sondern auch sie kaputt zu
halten denn Russland bemüht sich
natürlich diese Logistik
wiederherzustellen von daher wäre es gut
wenn die Ukraine auch aus Deutschland
lang reichweitiger Raketen bekommen
könnte damit sie den Erfolg den sie
jetzt haben in der nächsten Offensive
nächstes Jahr fortsetzen können
vielleicht noch dieser Ausblick zum
Schluss Dankeschön Herr Mölling dass sie
meine Fragen und die Fragen der
Community beantwortet haben und schönen
Abend noch
sehr gerne schönen Abend ciao
wie ist mit diesem potenziellen treffen
weitergeht wann es stattfindet was die
Ergebnisse sind und vor allem wie sie
den Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine
beeinflussen da bleiben wir für euch bei
ZDF heute live natürlich gerne weiter
dran danke schön dass ihr dabei wart und
bis zum nächsten Mal